-Now, more than ever,
it's important to remember
there are two sides
to every news story.
To make sure you get to see
important issues from all sides,
we've invited two of our writers
who have very different
points of view,
and we will examine
their opinions
in a segment we call
"Point/Counterpoint."
♪♪♪♪
Ally, Amber, thank you so much
for being here today.
Let's get started.
First topic.
President Trump has nominated
Judge Brett Kavanaugh
to replace retired Supreme Court
Justice Anthony Kennedy.
Could his appointment threaten
historic civil-rights
precedents?
Ally.
-Of course it will.
If he's confirmed, Roe v. Wade
will be the first thing
out the window.
Women have a better chance
of finding a unicorn
then a Republican who will
stand up for their rights.
-Amber.
-I love unicorns!
If I ever found one,
I would ride it everywhere
I went, even on the subway!
Ooh, and I'd name
my unicorn Paul,
'cause you can't be all flashy
all the time.
We'd be inseparable.
People would be like, "Amber
and Paul came over last night.
They ate all my sugar cubes!"
[ Laughter ]
-Another great point.
Next topic.
Despite clear intelligence
that Russia interfered with our
election and stole voter data,
Trump met with Vladimir Putin
in Helsinki.
What, if anything, was achieved
by this meeting? Ally.
-He legitimized a dictator
on the world stage,
didn't reproach Russia
for hacking our election,
and is helping Putin
by weakening NATO.
It's very clear Trump
is absolutely Putin's puppet.
-Amber?
-I love puppets.
Honestly, I think it's
the most overlooked art form.
Your hand becomes a person.
[ High-pitched ] And your
voice turns into this!
-I said Trump is Putin's puppet.
What do you think about that
specifically?
-[ Normal voice ] Ooh,
I wish a person was my puppet.
That would be so much fun.
Hey, Seth, move your lips.
[ High-pitched ]
"Hey, my name is Seth Meyers!
And I want all the jelly beans!"
-Seth, what's she saying
is completely off-topic.
-Ally, it's called
"Point/Counterpoint."
You get to make a point, she
gets to make the counterpoint.
-But doesn't her counterpoint
have to make sense?
-"No, it doesn't have to
make sense at all! Next topic."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The Trump administration wants
to end environmental protections
that would directly threaten
animals on the
endangered-species list.
Are we looking at
further extinctions? Ally.
-Of course we are!
Though, if we're being honest,
with Trump encouraging
climate change,
we're looking at human
extinction pretty soon, too.
So, sure, why not? Wipe out
innocent animals firsts.
And to think, Trump's
probably just doing this
for his gun-horny sons
who love paying
to hunt big-game trophies.
[ Scoffs ]
-Amber?
-I love trophies.
A little golden man is telling
you, "You did a good job."
And he's bowling just like me!
And I like that
you have to earn them.
You can't just buy them.
Unless you buy them, which I do!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is for you, Ally.
It says "Best Point"
'cause you have the best point.
-If you think I got you a trophy
for Best Counterpoint,
you are sorely mistaken.
-Good!
'Cause I got myself one!
Way to go, Amber!
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
-Next topic.
Despite federal judges ordering
the Trump administration
to reunite separated families
at the border,
hundreds of children remain
in detention centers alone.
How do we fix this disaster?
Ally.
-Honestly, I just wish
we could all exist
in the alternate reality
where Hillary won
and we're not dealing with
daily human-rights violations,
that I wouldn't be so upset
all the time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Cool! A happy Ally?
Huh. I want to live in
that alternate reality, too.
-Yeah, but how do we
make that happen?
-My magical unicorn, Paul.
He'll grant our wish.
-[ Laughs giddily ]
Your wish is granted!
[ Snorts ]
[ Harp plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Next topic.
Which are better --
cookies or brownies? Ally?
-Brownies are better
than cookies,
and anyone who disagrees
is a monster!
-Cookies are my favorite!
-Then you are a monster!
-Ally, I thought
when Hillary won,
you'd be less upset
about every-- [Laughs]
[ Laughter ]
-Have you met me?
[ Unicorn laughing, sobbing ]
It's so -- It's so funny.
-This has been another great
"Point/Counterpoint."